exactly what else
good morning yeah we're now calling the
order the community conference on house
bill 180 and act
increasing the penalty for buyers under
the laws regarding trafficking and
reversals
anyone just open up for discussion
um sometimes the sponsor of the
millennial has a couple of questions
um let's look at the house bill
um i guess the question for the house is
what is the difference in the age
you have a section that says three years
difference
it's on the second page um
what if the age is more than
three years difference then what happens
are you referring to roman numeral three
b
yes on the on the second pass by the
seven okay
by the house oh by the heart by the
house right
okay well i can't answer the part that
says
um for the person who's 13 years of age
or older
and under 16 years of age and the actor
is 20 years of age or under
the age difference between the actor and
the other person is not
more than three years so if it's more
than three years
then this section that section
would not have applied so then it would
revert back
in
the idea behind that was that the
mindset of someone who is let's say 18
or 19
it may be different than some if they
were to solicit someone
who was 15 or 16 as opposed to someone
who's
50 years old both of those are illegal
should remain illegal their crimes and
they're both supporting the market for
human trafficking
it's just the mindset of nine people
like presumably
different than that of uh 40 50 we'll
say 37
that's something it's not i think it's a
different offense
it's the same offense but i think if one
is more egregious than the other but
my understanding that that that
provision was
taken out and moved by the senate right
and
i i'm having conversations with
different
different members that are sitting here
today and some people outside this
community
i understand why taking it out it's
my point may be valid and logical
it's also makes sense to also not have
it in there because
again it it's still a crime i said this
in
the committee hearing in the house
criminal justice public safety committee
buyer beware
exactly um as far as the senate version
my question is the class a relates to
trafficking victims under the age of 16
correct
correct okay um
so 16 and 17 year old victims then
fall into the class b felony uh 17 and
18. and it
revolves around the age of consent
because the age of consent is 16.
um we had some difficulty with
13 years and and that three year time
period
because we felt that there are children
that are younger the age younger than
the age of 13 that are also trafficked
so that's why in the new section b
we changed it to a class a felony and we
have
for the person who is under the age of
16.
um and we wanted the harsher penalty for
that
because they're not capable legally
capable and you could even argue
intellectually capable of consenting
to to to a sex act with
an older person um or even um
you could even say you know someone
who's 18 or older
um the first one we we kept the class b
felony because of the age of consent you
you do
you can give the your consent at that
particular point in time
to uh to consent even though you are
being trafficked
you can saying
yes or no i'm not going to do that so we
our emphasis was really on the 16
and younger because of the age of
consent
yeah and the cargo didn't really make
sense to us because
you know again we're talking about
trafficking as you know this is not
these are relationships uh and so the
cargo really didn't
make sense uh based on what you're
talking
again if we're talking about a 17 year
old victim then we're talking about
the fact that they the offender would be
charged with the process being filmed
correct
and then the other question um why was
the removal of the section on the
knowledge of
an actor by not knowing the age
of the person that they can
cannot use that as a defense because
that was where i worked on
several years ago and i just feel that
um like daryl said
this fire yeah i see that yeah we buy
everywhere
yeah we we do have that in the first
section right but not in the second
so does that mean it's time like a
little second section maybe that is
something that we can talk about
yeah i think we can we can add that to
the second step no
i think that was a drafting sort of yeah
it might have been a drafting and also
um
i mean you should know if someone's
16 or younger i mean granted there are
a lot of adults and young adults
or teenagers and this applies to both
men and women although we usually just
think of women being trafficked
uh young boys are also trapped as well
um
that they you should know
you should know anyone between the ages
of 17 you
really should but if you have a 10 year
old
i mean come on you you know that that
person is not capable of giving consent
even up to the age of 16 which is the
legal age of consent
that you really should know who you're
having a sexual
sexual contact with that
but anyway that's but i do think that
perhaps um
that was an oversight that and we can
talk about
in an amendment to put that in there as
well right because
my feeling was you know like daryl says
sending representatives
that buyer beware is definitely
and the other part of it is is the fact
that
you're committing an offense when you're
buying sex with
anybody in the state of new hampshire
it's a misdemeanor
so you've already broken the law so
therefore
to use as a defense that you didn't know
the age of
the person you had sex with i don't
think that should be allowed
to the event because they've already
broken the law and this
is just this step is even more egregious
what we what we really concentrated on
was the fact that
we felt that there should be stricter
penalties for children for someone
trafficking children and someone who
buys sexual services from a child
um rather than someone who is legally
able to
uh give their consent right so i
mr chair we would have um no problem
in adopting a compromise amendment
putting the language neither the actor's
lack of knowledge of the other person's
age nor consent to the other person
shall constitute a defense to a charge
under this paragraph
to include that in paragraph
i would support that any any other
thoughts or considerations
no i don't know i just i just wanted to
say though
that anybody who has been trafficked i
mean
and it stays with that person
for life yes and so you know we don't
want to minimize
because of ages we want to acknowledge
that
it's egregious no matter what age of the
child so that is
just something i needed to say okay
thank you
i'll just point out that i think that
again this is a fair compromise between
both divisions here so let's see
if i wear this correctly if i don't wear
this right someone correct me so it's
efficient
so the house is not we're not receiving
our position of non-concurrence but
with the senate amendment but we will
concur with a an amendment
that addresses paragraph three
b roman numeral 3b that takes the
language
that um neither the actor
neither the actor's lack of knowledge of
the other person's age
or nor consent of the other person shall
constitute defense to recharge
into this paragraph provided that there
is an amendment that simply
adds that provision from number 3b uh
the house would then
proceed and concur with the senate
yes
excellent
you all ready to rock roll yes morning
we will now call the
order the committee conference on on
house bill 239 and act relative to the
prosecution of certain
assaults against minors
this is a bill that originally passed in
the house that was then
subsequently amended by the senate
before we again would just start by
letting everyone introduce themselves
i'll start with that
i'm harold franklin district seven
i'm sharon carson senator district 14.
good morning becky whitley i'm the
senator from district 15.
i am ray newman representative 29
national
scott wallace representative danville
rockingham 12.
jennifer rhodes representative district
15 cheshire county
representative darrell abbott
representing rockingham county
distributed and i think just to begin
we'll start with
if someone could explain the immense
amendment that has been added to the
original book
thank you very much mr chairman um this
bill was a little problematic for us
because
we only had the testimony of front
sponsor we had
no no one from the legal community no
one from
advocates whether they were legal
advocates or children advocates
or nothing just that and we felt
uncomfortable
with uh with the six years originally
i believe we we had moved this bill
in expedient to legislate but in talking
with some of my colleagues we decided
okay let's see what we can do
and so we brought in a floor amendment
that
we said three years why don't we just do
three years
so um in talking with my colleagues
what i would like to do is offer a
compromise to the house
in which we will have an amendment
which would if you look at
as introduced um section
one g not withstanding sub-paragraphs a
and b
for any offense under rsa 631-1
which are the serious offenses where
you're talking about
rape murder you know physical real
physical harm that we will go to the six
years
but force rsa 631-2
which is uh usually second-degree
assaults that we will go to
three years and that is the compromise
we will offer to you
hi thank you for
that compromise one of the the concerns
that i have
is that i don't believe
that a person that is a victim of these
crimes
necessarily sometimes even
realizes or experiences the true effects
of this assault at the age of
21 or 22. and if you take a person that
is
18 years old maybe recently graduates
college at 19
21 years old
comes into the rural world per se a lot
of times
that's when these this kind of really
hits them like a sledgehammer
and they they kind of tend to go
backwards a little bit into a shell
and also that is whenever they have the
courage more
to come out to talk about what has
really happened
so it almost feels like well if you
didn't do it in time
then the punishment isn't as extreme so
i i feel very strongly and i know our
committee felt very strongly
in about the six years and i just don't
think that it should make a difference
um what was done what was done is was
not okay
period and i would i would just really
encourage you to think about
the thing about that our concern
was that the further you get away from
the incident
the more difficult it's going to be to
prove um
memory issues um other people that
were involved the other the other person
are the people
that were involved i mean it just
becomes harder it
just becomes much harder and so
um we felt you know just based upon the
testimony we had
we understand that we know that there
are times we
have depressed memories um they don't
realize what happened to them
at that particular time but again we did
not get the testimony that we needed
from the legal uh from the legal
community and or
uh the other types of advocates so
that's why originally we just said look
we don't have the testimony we need
um we're just gonna itl this send a
message to the uh
talk to the prime sponsor but please
file this again
bring the people forward to talk with us
about this
but again um in reflection we said okay
wait a minute
let's we'll we'll divide it in half
we'll go three years
and so that's what we did and so now
we're we're willing to go okay
for the really serious crimes we'll go
six years but for these
other types of the lesser crimes we'll
do three
as an effort of compromise
yeah and i think sort of thinking
through uh
you know i i see what you're saying in
terms of um
you know when people will come to the
realization that something happened
and of course you know sometimes it
doesn't happen when they're outside
of their home right so sometimes someone
who
is a victim is under the care of a
relative and that's the perpetrator and
so
you know three years from the 18th
birthday does give them additional
three years to sort of the outcome or
even the legal
um that's the legal
provision of the the first of the
perpetrator so
i think it is a compromise position i
think you know if we get additional
testimony next year about whether six
years
were appropriate based on brain
development i think that would be really
important
to know the brain development of someone
from 18 but i think this is an
appropriate compromise
based on our
it's no good question for anyone sitting
here but
this has to do with the civil liability
did
last term i know there was a senate
it was a senate bill that would have
made it
had erased the status limitations on on
civil case for
sexual assault now
i think yeah
i think um i'm not sure if that was part
of an ominous bill or not
but i do remember um senate judiciary
had that
i believe that it was passed i'm gonna
take a chance here and say
i think it was part of an operative
spill that that
i think it initially was a stand-alone
that got then put into it
after the pandemic began not that
civil liability is necessarily justice
but at least that but there is no status
limitations on that
so like that person could still
have their their day in court and
i'm not saying money would solve the
problem but there's something to keep in
mind
bringing the difference attention and i
think three years from the 18th birthday
is still like
dramatic progress
your current law is really problematic
so if i understand correctly the
proposal is
first degree assault that would be
moved back up to six years but ending
second degree
is remaining three years
i would agree to that for compromise i
just feel
i just really have to say that i i don't
think
limiting a person when they're in this
situation
to an age i i feel like it's almost
it's almost telling them too bad so sad
you know you didn't come out soon enough
and in the whole culture that we're in
the world that we're in now is to
encourage people and
to tell them that they're limited on
how long they have to to do this i mean
it's really
really hard for a person that is in that
situation
and you know where senator you made a
great point
a lot of these these people are in
situations where
it very well may have been a family
member maybe some in their own household
and
it takes them to get out of that so i i
almost feel like
telling them when you didn't do it in
time you know i
i personally should be any limit but i
recognize there needs to be
i would agree to a compromise because it
is better than nothing i just really
feel like
i need to say i just i really encourage
you to just
i could be longer not sooner but
last term there was a bill proposing
in the house it didn't make it out of
the house
but i recall being i they would have had
no stash of limitations from
criminal offences i think that was
i was the not many people supported i
know i did
so i i'm i'm with you on expanding even
more but
i kind of tend to agree in the spirit of
compromise because what we have now if
we don't come from
what we have now is works i mean they'll
agree something needs to be done i agree
someone said that i think the more
serious offenses at least
that would be in six years and if
if at any point in time we think three
years is too short
of degree assaults i'll postpone
treatment
thank you for standing up
situation so i just have a question
about
there's 26 the difference between three
and
going by the most serious events a
little less serious defense
maybe misunderstanding when you need a
better understanding of what statute of
limitations does
if one of these crimes are committed
then the statute of limitations
basically i think protects the
perpetrator it seems like that's who
who by changing these uh number of years
it affects the perpetrator the victim
then is the opportunity to report that
crime
so i'm having i agree i think it should
be longer rather than shorter
and i don't see really the need to
compromise at all from 63.
maybe my misunderstanding
and i may i agree with you up to the
point that
if i got everything i asked for in every
single build the
laws would be very different i actually
agreed that i i would be
okay making it nine or even twelve
because
nowadays with some of the technology we
have and some of the
dna databases that you're able to
sometimes you can always find the person
so and now we're dealing with miners
we're not even open enough to consent to
testifying so i i'm right there with you
but i think
i supposed to do nothing is worse than
i think the compromise is fair
considering that it's it's
first degree that assault sexual
assaults that's that's the serious most
serious
serious that's not the undermined second
degree that's also sierra's put out
i would be reluctant to let this one
slip away because
where we would be is back square one and
i i'm confident that our
what the committee the house criminal
justice public safety committee would do
but i see i see us repeating ourselves
we'll be
sitting here again next year
i would not want to see the bill slip
away but i'm not sure that i agree
that compromise for the purposes of
saying we compromise
to get the legislation right that's the
only way to get it then
that's how we'll get it if you want to
try to convince
how we keep the four's yours
it they're very reasonable everyone
we're all reasonable here i understand
that's casual and i i mean you get
in a situation where you have some
some of this maybe within a family
repetitive or whatever it could affect a
whole bunch of money
i i just don't see a need to change the
statute of limitations
you don't have a case you don't press
the case
so i mean everybody's saying yeah i
think we should have higher ones but
just to compromise to save your company
last five but
that's what but
in fairness that if i thought the
compromise was
unreasonable i wouldn't compromise i'm
not saying that i'm going to leave here
celebrating but at the same time i
i think the compromise is reasonable my
question was that
the legislative end of it my question
was
just to understand what i thought about
about station limitations i think they
should be wrong
that's my opinion
[Music]
it's a different question right rather
we should have such a location yeah
that's right
that's that's a very different question
and i would just like to make the point
representative
we went from killing this bill to now
we're at the point where for the serious
offenses we agree to six years the less
serious offenses
will will go to three years so i think
the senate has
moved on our position a great deal uh
it's it's unfortunate that we just did
not get a lot of testimony on this bill
we just had the prime sponsor and that's
it
and just so everyone understands who's
following along
three years six years it may sound short
this is a tolling
statute location so you can have a it's
total it's a tolling status meaning
a hypothetical if you had a victim that
was 13
for the first once they reset 18 that's
when the clock starts
so it's it's precisely longer than three
longer than six and for you know good
reason that it's really been told
it's so it's you could be prosecuting or
trying to prosper someone
for an offense that happened 15 years
ago 10 years ago
and i'm not going to i'm wondering if
there was testimony provided about why
the case
for all children and minors
it said that your brain
during that period relies on mainly the
pottery brain with that
emotion so there's a lot of emotional
things tied up with that
it goes to a different part of your
brain and you get to be 25
and in the meantime
most of the things you're doing are
emotional so it might be even something
about where
people at that age of 23
they remember the statute of limitation
somebody
might not realize till at 23 or 24 that
what they thought was perfectly okay
or something figured out so
so i don't have a problem doing the
statute limitations because we did have
that kind of testimony
why why six years and another thing is
that we heard it as ludicrous as this
may sound
when this is happening to a child
it's perfectly normal to them they think
it's very normal that
that is their normalcy to us it's hard
to imagine
because it's just that ludicrous to them
seven eight nine years old you know i
worked in a school
you would be amazed how many
how many children think
if that's just that happens to everybody
that's very very normal
so again once they once they reach a
certain age and they
start to experience more life and then
that's when things kind of start
hitting them left and right
unfortunately you know a lot of these
people end up
having to resign from their jobs you
know live with their parents it's just
it's really really hard i just don't
think we should
there's something that you should can't
come from too
officially with the proposed amendment
which would i'll just say it again it
would be
for for any first degree would change
from six years from
specialization six years from the 18th
birthday for any second degree
it would be three years
because if does anyone have any
objection
to that if that would be
and we all would we also give that up
yes there we have it
thank you everyone
good morning we now call the order of
the committee at conference on house
bill 296
an act establishing the crime of
unsolicited disclosures
of an intimate image
this bill that passed the house that was
then amended
subsequently amended
all right but just before we get into
that we will now introduce the
members that are present
senator carson i represent district 14.
i'm not representative allison that i
won i represent
nashua or hillsboro 32.
representative scott wallace rockingham
12 the town of danville
representative general rhodes represents
cheshire county district 15.
representative darryl abbess i represent
rockingham county district eight
and
at this point i understand that there's
an amendment already prepared
so rather than maybe discuss what the
what was amended when it was in the
other
branch uh we can just discuss the
amendments
does then have anyone had a chance to
review that look through that
so to sum it up what inspired this was
in both uh versions that passed
had language where in order to meet
their burden you have to
prove the intent to harass and
it was raised at least brought to our
attention that
to prove the intent to harass
would be very difficult to prove um
unless it was
something more of a repeat situation
so considering the offense would only
have been a violation offense
it was found that this law would have
actually been very harmful because it
wouldn't have been something that was
really
enforceable and although well intended
may have left some something to be
desired because it wasn't
accomplished
what i can just say from speaking with
you know it's not that law enforcement
officials won't enforce violations but
that's
that's a lower level offense it's
naturally going to be a lesser priority
so it is better to
for this to have at least be the
misdemeanor level so what the amendment
does it makes the first offense
to be a misdemeanor it does not specify
whether it's a class a or a class b
misdemeanor
that would be at the discretion of the
county attorney
on how they wish to prosecute that
um the difference obviously being the
class b just
did not entail any uh jail time at least
uh if there were to be a second offense
presuming that
there was a the first offense there was
already a conviction
uh that would then elevate the charge to
the potential of a class d felony and
these have to do with when the loot
images are sent
they're unsolicited by the person
receiving them
and what this also does is it takes us
where
the recipient does not solicit the photo
and that recipient is a minor
that in of itself would then be a
class b felony
that's what this does then it also has a
provision on the registration
for the uh criminal offenders um
it does add rsa 644.9-b
that i again we're talking about i
understand this may not be a physical
act
it's still a backup
involving loot images being especially
involved in a minor
i don't have a problem with that
especially protection
i have a hard time objecting to that
and i'll open up for discussions of
interviews just to speak on it
hey um mr chairman i'm just looking here
from senator um
[Music]
the i i i can see what this amendment is
trying to do
um and i think that
um
my concern is with the registration um
so if someone's convicted of them guilty
of a misdemeanor for the first offense
are they going to be placed on the
is that clear because i can i can
definitely see
under roman four anyone who sends a
photograph to a child
be considered to be on the uh
on the sex offender list but if you're
talking about
um someone who does it once
is that automatically going to put that
on the sex offender once
my understanding this is rsa 644
449-b
um that that's referencing
the roman numeral four that says
notwithstanding paragraph two any person
who violates this paragraph by
transmitting such an image to a child
shall be guilty of a class b felony so
my understanding that would involve when
the recipient of the unsolicited image
as a child
they would be put in the registry i
don't believe
if it if the recipient is an adult it
would necessarily invoke that
i think all right we'll talk about that
on our side
any other comments
can we take a few minute break
uh
morning uh we're now reconvening uh
the comedian conference on the house of
296 attack establishing the crime
unsolicited disclosure of an intimate
image
it was some discussion and there was
amendment 2021-2000h
and is there any i would ask this be
some further discussion
um mr chairman thank you um as i said
this was another bill where we only had
one person testified which was
new representatives through bill um and
since that time um we've gotten um
some input there is a version that was
adopted by the senate and
again that's why we're here we have the
side side by side
and we've received this this morning um
there seems to be a lot of work this is
a very important piece of legislation
and we want to be very very careful
about what we're doing
we know that in today's society
people do this all the time and
uh for whatever reasons i i don't
for me i don't know maybe it's a
generational thing it's like
why would you do this but people do this
and so what we're looking at here is
really a division between adults and
children
and we're struggling with the adult
behavior because someone can
send you a picture and it's like yeah
most adults will go yeah whatever and
throw it away and not really pay that
much attention to it
um you have people that solicit these
types of pictures
um and so we're just concerned about
really scooping up a whole bunch of
people
especially adults that you really don't
want to scoop up
um so i'm hoping that we can agree
as a starting point that children
that this happening to kids but because
children cannot give their consent
that perhaps we can just kind of focus
on
kids and what happens to children
because i think we can
all agree that for a child to receive on
a
on a device whether it's an ipad or
computer
or if kids are have cell phones
that that is unacceptable that no child
should
get these types of photos even if their
kids training amongst themselves
we know kids do this stuff that it's
inappropriate behavior
and it needs to be addressed um
that's where we are and it's just a
question of finding
the right language that will focus on
minors and at at another
point and probably as a second part
perhaps legislation can get filed
that will deal with the issue with adult
behavior
um because that's what we're struggling
with
so it may inquire of a question so we if
roman numeral two and three well
let's just say those two numerals
weren't there those paragraphs were
moved
so i think we all agree paragraph four
is is something that you don't like
what about silver
i read this as technically the technical
language that a
child could solicit
a um intimate image
and that's something that they could do
and technically the person wouldn't fall
under this because it was
solicited this has to do when it's like
meaning that
a child is on perceiving this
intimate image without any
any act of their own to action justify
it
i think it needs to be made clear that
the child does not have the ability to
consent
so even if even if you've got two kids
that are you know trading these they
want to you know hey i want to send you
a picture of this and
you don't children legally don't have
the ability to consent to either send or
receive those images
but i think consent for statutory rape
purposes i want to say
i you're correct but i'm not i'm not
clear that that consent would apply
here i think that's just because keep in
mind
that the images going back and forth
especially if the image is involves a
child who's still
going to be following the chakra so
whether this passes
or or not that's still going to remain
the law so that's still going to remain
a crime it's also
um
i guess i guess i'm just would we change
the language of power before to
put that in there that in any
circumstance
so it falls upon the other person not
the child
to be responsible enough to know that
they know that they're sending
a child the problem that it creates a
defense
well i was sending this out i didn't
know what was going to a child
so but then again i guess you can go the
other way too
if an image is sent
and they missed it and a child ends up
with it
and that is not the same situation
i understand that miss sending it can
happen again
people were going to send intimate
images and they sent us
the wrong mistake i don't know
i don't know i'm not sure what i don't
know what to say i i understand
it's a good point but
it's it has a new not that has a number
that
previously won something else right so i
still think you're you're
gonna be the act of sending it right
i'm not gonna send naked pictures of
people well that
that would
um two um
letter c um um so a person
is guilty of a misdemeanor such person
fornicates exposes
his or her genitals or reforms any sort
of any act of grossness under
circumstances which
he or she he or she should know
will likely cause a frontal alarm um a
person is guilty of a class b felony if
and then c is um such person
purposely transmits to a child who is
less than 16 years
of age or an individual whom the actor
reasonably believes is a child less than
16 years of age
an image of himself or herself
fornicating exposing desert congenitals
or performing any other act of gross
moodness so the situation we're talking
about it's already a cry
so sending it to a child is already a
felony
so i'm not really sure where the issues
amendment's supposed to be fixing the
perhaps accidental um
yeah i guess what we're like i'm just
confused i feel like we're talking about
already a crime so this really is just
for adults
submit like good stuff
i think what this what this does though
in this particular case
if it's two adults and the sender and
the receiver
the first offense will be a misdemeanor
if the second offense can be
class b the
but if the recipient is a child it's
although it's already a crime
what it's saying is it won't the first
offense there will not be a misdemeanor
it will be a basketball
and they're bypassing if that's a rate
of law then
uh i i suppose i we don't want to change
that by
confuse that issue by patrick castle
removal two or three even
let's just say we passed whether it's
the house version or
if we took the amendments made it in the
in the other quality i mean that reduces
to a violation and
i go back to that i don't when it comes
to
prosecuting that if it's a violation one
the person's not facing any jail time
you take that the distance and you're
not going to have
those shouldn't and i would not in
respect to the
effect it's a violation it's going to
just naturally be low priority
so making it a misdemeanor at least gets
some some teeth and it's this is
happening all the time part of it is
that well there's no there's no penalty
for doing it
and yeah that's why it's running rampant
apparently something needs to be done
and i don't at this amendment
i think put some protection in there and
i think it's it's already it's
strengthening or clarifying
the law already and i again i if you
send
the photo accidentally the wrong person
i
sympathize with the situation but just
full yeah
i would hope you're very careful with
what you send me out there because what
you're sending out there will be
if we can look at i mean the the senate
version didn't deal with
separating out adults from children and
you're
right representative there is a whole
nother statute and that was
part of the problem because we had
people talking about revenge pornography
we already covered that
so if you look at what the senate did we
changed he or she was person
um but it's with the intent to harass
that they're doing it to harass you now
if somebody
said who said by mistake sends you a
photo
and you're like wait a minute i don't
want to see this
did they do it on purpose did they do it
to harass you versus
was it a mistake and you look at the la
the house language
you have annoyed or alarmed um
i don't know how you how do you how does
that how does that work
that's why we use we use the word with
the intention
it was sent deliberately to you to
harass you
in some manner and then um it says the
person knows the recipient has not
consented
you didn't ask for it they they sent it
to you
um and you did not consent to receive it
and
that you were harassed by you felt
harassed by the image
and then it says any person who violates
the provisions of deception shall be
guilty of a
violation first offense and a
misdemeanor for the second or subsequent
event
if the person at the court finds a
person has been convicted of a violation
of this section
so that's where that's how we got to
where we are
i i think this is confusing people i and
i understand
you know why that's there but we you're
right representative we already have the
statute for kids so why
why is this even here and i think the
idea of putting these folks
on the um sex offender list
i mean is a very very serious something
because once you're on the sex offender
list it's virtually impossible
and so how do these folks get on me on
this list
um and what's the criteria for getting
them on the list
so i i would like if we're gonna look at
this i'd like to not deal with the sex
offender
issue quite frankly because i think
you're going to capture people that you
don't really want to
the statute that's represented by
identified republican decency
is included
[Music]
the concern would be is that would any
version that's passed whether that's the
house of the
seventh amendment would that
water it down to the point that well
what is now roman numeral for on the
proposed amendment would that not be the
case then
it sounds to me like what we passed
already
would actually remove children from
if the recipient is a child we're now
removing them
from being put into registry it's going
to be a violation
so this amendment was to address that
because i don't think that was what any
of us
wanted to do i think i can say that
so just we in agreement on that at least
whether we like the whether we follow
the amendment or not i'm saying is
what we pas i'm not going to support
what was originally passed and i'll take
responsibility
i voted for a committee i don't
reference but it's been brought to my
attention
the unattended consequence so i'm
thankful i have an opportunity to
correct that
so i i
still think this is something needs to
be addressed whether we address it now
or here i guess it's a really good
question
but i i think what this does is
fix that i think it fixes the problem
because i don't think anyone wants to
make it so a child can receive
unsolicited
you know image you know depicting a
sexual act
and the person who sends it is a bit of
a violation
of a fine my concern is we already have
that captured in statute already and i'm
concerned that if we pass
this you could get a contract
and this is the problem not having the
time to really
look at what's already in law and what's
being proposed
what was the rsa that you um
additionally there was a harass
mention well
it could be evidence yeah i mean you can
make it if you do it three four times
over right
it's pretty evident that's your
intention yeah and and that this is
where
you don't want to capture the person who
oh my god
i accidentally you know i texted it to
somebody
that shouldn't
is whether it's the house version or
the amendment they have if that
i don't think we can advance that
because the problem is with that is
arguably the rsa here on point it will
conflict with that
in that case if you do send a child a
new damage
that it would be nothing more than a
violation i don't think we want that so
if we're not going to
move forward with the amendment i would
i would not support going forward at all
and i say we we work together and try to
resolve this yeah next year
and we tend to agree because again this
is an extremely
important issue and unfortunately on
our side the only testimony we had was
from you representative we didn't have
the legal community none of the
advocates they
they've all chimed in now at the very
last minute
with possible amendments and you know
and
we just need to be really careful about
what we're doing here
and i just don't want to create a law
that is going to catch a lot of
innocent people who made just a very
simple mistake
um and granted look i'm not judging
anybody if you like to take pictures of
yourself that's fine
but sometimes it happens that someone
makes a mistake and
they send it to the wrong person and i
just can't see that person
um
[Music]
it may be worth noting that the thing
that's currently in law
is both broader and narrower it's
narrower because it
defines adults 60 and under rather than
18 and under
is broader because the
prime is defined as um
uh fornicates exposes or democracy
performs any other prototype of lupus
that's broader than the conduct that's
in the existing bill so it captures more
images than what's
i will say i supported the underlying
i think we hoped i think we we all
support the concept of
what was trying to accomplish but i i'm
worried about the unintended consequence
of now
reducing the penalty from from the
um i take some responsibility for
missing that
i'm not perfect but it happened but if
i'm not comfortable comfortable uh
proceeding to any
amendment unless we adopt the one that
we proposed
just from our conversation i'm not sure
we're going to get there
so if that's the case
yeah do you have any thoughts
i mean i understand um
i don't know who's accidentally sending
photos
that wouldn't be a crime but i
understand that
i'm not always gonna get my way um
and that i don't think of all things
um i really like this amendment i think
it fixes
all the problems i think all the issues
we've talked about are already addressed
in law
i will give you my word on this if
this amendment was to be filed as a i'll
still next year i
will co-sponsor with you thank you
will happen is uh see how it fairs in
one committee
um we'll try our luck
i have a lot of surprises in there but
we'll see but
if we don't have if we don't have the
support to put this for now
i would respectfully say we
advancing on what you know receding on
or whatever
it's not going to work either i would
join
that
any comments now
it's what it is uh so what we'll do is
we won't give up in this issue
there's there's going to be legislation
we already know
other senators that's very interested in
this issue
we're not what the terminology is
we're very close we are close but
before we can bring
good morning everyone uh we're now uh
call the order at the committee
conference on house bill 334
does not have the title yet so someone
carrying a loaded firearm on an ohrv or
snowmobile
thank you and i just never can introduce
i'm themselves bob knighter from
district 2. uh senator carson from
district 14.
senator jay kahn from key and cheshire
uh representative roy from rockingham 32
representative scott wallace rockingham
as well
representative jennifer rhodes chester
county district 15.
representative darrell avis representing
rockingham county district eight
and i think we'll just there was an
amendment that
asked in the senate and i was allow that
to be explained
so thank you mr chair oh you want me to
take this
or do you know because i'm the one who
did it
so the uh the amendment was essentially
to attach
a bill of similar substance central 141
to away with the state police gun line
which has been problematic that will
pass the house and the senate is
currently enrolled in process
what we want to do is develop suspenders
with this amendment
to ensure that
nice it's passed saying
that's essentially that's the
legislation that was passed by the house
and senate
senator 141
to bring this forward and state
suspenders for the bill that is
currently enrolled but
for which we have no shots
is it inviting may inquire this
amendment
may is say word for word or at least
almost word for word
what was senator 141 it is that is
passed in both the house
there's one point that we just found out
from
olier that in the final language i
believe
after section nine
effective data language there or too
there's an amendment because
humburger wants to put into this bill
abolishing the actual positions that
deal with the gun line
in the state base
and that amendment is currently almost
it's imprinting literally as we speak
so i'd like to request a recess for
five or ten minutes until that is done
tracking that
again we just found this out about half
hour about an hour
i i will say we're behind schedule we do
have uh there is another uh committee
conference
for house bill 45 that was scheduled for
11 30. we could
move on to that and put this uh recess
about 334 right now we will be in recess
uh community conference center hospital
334 will be new sites
we will start by just allowing everyone
to introduce produce themselves
starting with yourself harold frank
senator district 7.
senator carson senate district 14.
senator jay kahn senate district 10
representing keane
and 15 treasury representatives
rockingham 32 representative scott
wallace rockingham
representative john bourdain
representing cheshire five
representative darryl avas representing
rockingham county
district
so we can begin this was uh there was
several um well there was
an amendment that added several
provisions to this that i would say
i'm related to the underlying bill but
is that reserve a lot of those
my understanding have either passed or
been resolved in other
legislation yes um if i may mr chairman
um as you know we've been meeting in a
variety of committee conferences over
the
since monday and we uh
we came to an agreement on senate bill
which was filed by senator french which
dealt with this
very same issue of the underlying
485 and i had attached
a bill to this because we were concerned
we were going to lose the bill but
yesterday
the committee of conference met and we
came to an agreement
so that language is no longer needed
either so
um my recommendation is this bill we
don't need this bill
in its entirety all right
i agree with you is anyone else
any other further comments which which
um bill did related thing
about that um
yesterday and i know there was an issue
with the
police in rockingham county involving
some of the recording of plans
that was resolved yes as well so yeah
the
amendment was a hybrid of both the
house and the senate version we worked
off of the house version
because again you had language in here
that we did not that we had agreed with
and it was just one other section in
there that we were concerned about but
we came from search of vehicles our
corrections properly yes
yeah we had to make a correction
any other comments looks like that
we are we are not going to proceed and
there's not going to be any there's
gonna be no concurrence so
no actually taken thank
probably a you minutes on cynical
in the community conference on house
bill 334
my understanding is that there's now
been there was an amending
amendment pending that has now been
prepared
and senator goddard you may remind uh
thank you to us the amendment fixes
some technical details your indulgence i
would ask
heaven to speak to it admit i'm sorry
speaker you may speak foreign
good morning uh for the record uh mickey
for the record mickey landrigan with the
legislative budget assistance office
uh so i can walk you through amendment
s so there are a couple budget uh
technical corrections being made here
in align with the intent with senate
bill 141 as well as the language that
was inserted in house bill 334
so starting with section 9 this would be
the 100 000 appropriation to the county
sheriff's office
the language that's in both senate bill
141 and
334 makes that a charge to a certain
class line and accounting unit in the
department of safety in fiscal year
2021.
those funds are not available in that
amount to do the intent here
so if you look at amendment 2014 s
section 9 would be replaced by a
straightforward general fund
appropriation in fiscal 22 for the same
purpose
in section 10 of amendment 2 0 1 4 s
this would be the abolishment of three
positions in the permitting licensing
accounting unit
and if you look at on line 15
paragraph 2 you'll see the corresponding
general fund
appropriation reduction for those
positions so there is a net here
of about a three hundred thousand dollar
budget reduction
um in this amendment to reflect the
intent of the gun line abolishment
in the bill
might have i inquire of a question so
this would was that 300 000
100 reduction in spending today here
correctly the 100 000 would be an
appropriate state spend to the counties
and then there'd be a 400
000 on line 17 appropriation reduction
in the department of safety for a net of
three hundred thousand dollar spending
reduction
in in the follow-up that four hundred
four and one thousand six hundred fifty
dollars is that
what was that money why was that going
to go to fund what was
referred to as the gun line yeah that
that is included currently
in house bill 1 that the countries have
uh
signed off on that report so those three
positions you see listed on lines 12
through 14
that's the funding associated with those
positions they are in the budget
this amendment here would abolish those
positions from the budget and take the
money
from the budget
thank you
interesting uh saying that the fiscal
note on 141 was eighty seven thousand
dollars
so just one year of the math camp
for that
math for this is my
alliance for those positions
that's the jobs that are being
eliminated and the hundred thousand is
the money that's going into the account
that we can't appropriate in the issues
the question is it just seems like a big
jump big difference in the numbers that
the fiscal low was 87
000 and we're eliminating 200 or
300 000 roughly from this why
well there's been some changes in
personnel safety is hired to personnel
to re-staff the government okay
substance that will be introduced they
had eight troopers off the line you
don't get the details of the bill
because it's been passed by the house
and senate
they took eight troopers off the line to
staff the gun line to catch things up
now they're adding through personnel
those eight troopers go back to the line
those three personnel are coming out of
the budget it's
from my field trip to the uh gun line
three or four weeks ago
there's one trooper that's assigned
currently there were eight that during
the probe
they weren't out on the road i'm not
going to argue the mayor's new
representative because that's already
been voted on by both chambers
all right 400 1 000 is the amount of
three positions for the gun line that
have been eliminated by the statute by
the appendix
if i can inquire so i understand that
that 141
is passed and on its way
will be on its way at some point
hypothetically speaking if that
that 141 was vetoed for whatever reason
what would then have if we eliminate
these positions but also
bill's veto what does that mean if you
read on line 18 section 11
the question
oh hey that was addressed
in fairness this is just him no no me
too so yeah
so for some reason senate bill 141 was
not signed into law
then those positions would not be
eliminated that's that's important
now
is senate bill 141 at least sorry the
amendment
that was made to 334 otherwise someone
still have
language in there as well it's the same
the same as 141 this will amend
that language 3334 so it's consistent
with the budgeting
i i think the purpose is if we're going
to eliminate the government
then this makes sense to eliminate the
400 000
that was going to allocate the funding
that the employees hired to
you know address the demand that they
have so that makes
not only makes sense whether we support
support getting rich or not i mean if
it's going it's just the right thing to
do
mr jared i'll make a motion that we
adopt um
amendment number two zero one for us
okay all right next question
uh that if
senate bill 141 does
not take effect sections 9 and 10
of this bill 334
would
on line 24
explains how that works if 141
and we're taught we're not talking about
this film we're talking about
example 141 which is on its own track
um uh becomes law sections
three uh three through eight of this act
shall not take effect in section seven
of senate bill 141 shall not take effect
if senate bill 141 does not become a
loss
section three and eight through eight of
this act shall take effect
so if if for whatever reason if senator
won
the governor vetoes that you have to
leave
these other two things in place in order
to make a gun line work
so these two parts will not take effect
at all
i will say if if you have the gun line
in
existence and it was unable to work
at all uh in and of itself would
essentially prevent any
legal firearm transaction involving
pistols
um the state would have a huge amount of
lawsuits on their hands that they would
like to resolve
because they are effectively denying
anyone any
lawful purchase of a firearm piece of
pistol
through the gun line because it's now
not staffed so if you're going to have
the gun line it must
at least operate in a way that it can
perform
appropriately if there's no one to
operate it and everything's in limbo
not only at the constitutional issue all
those scores
elected by business may i ask the
question mr london
yes sir
if senate bill 141 does not become
law and
senate bill 334
does
so 334
to make sure that i understand so
hypothetically yeah
it's the gun line if veto takes place on
unlikely but if it happened
uh then uh
334 would be there
and if 334 was then signed into one
then would these continuously still be
afflicted is that
what you're inquiring about these these
are going to take effect
if i may so i think the intent would be
for sections 9 and 10
to take effect if 334 passes right
because you've got all the
language from 141 in 334 now so
so the abolishment of the gun line would
occur in 334
in these sections nine and ten i believe
it's the intent to have those also take
effect the reduction in safety
there's no way for nine and ten to
become law without
is there any other further discussions
yeah
i just did say i'm in opposition
to uh to this and uh i'm
likely not in agreement with
the inclusion of 141
language in the 334 bill
the underlying bill is one that i would
like to be voting for
but i believe that the state's role
with the gun line and department of
safety
is a valuable one and
it's working well enough that
and we've heard that through testimony
and so i believe that
and support that
line of thought hence i i mean not
i don't vote against this but i will
likely uh
need to resign from this body
with
i could say on behalf of the house and i
was remembered to
say they're coming i
we did the house position was we ended
up passing
the bill 141 so and we also passed
uh hb 334 uh
so how's position would be to support
both
i think this is the fiscal responsible
version of what
i would ultimately assume this should
have happened if you're going to
eliminate the downline so i don't have a
problem with amendment
zero one 2021-2014 does anyone know
anyone have any comments um
opposition
we just rips the roads at your ear walls
i share some of the khan's position the
gun
is doing a good job there has been some
props in the past
took some time went out there and did a
field inspection
everything's working well this is kind
of a surprise not what we were expecting
at all today
it is a surprise i will say that i'm
surprised
but i i think i think with what it is
without knowing what it is is hard to
comment on
issue well i'll just say in respect to
i understand supporting and not
supporting
new hampshire downline if that's
abolished or not i get that
one senator 121 is already on its way up
the ladder so
i guess if it worked if it were going to
pass
and let's say we couldn't get this
amendment what would happen
arguably there would be a few state
employees
three of them i believe with not much to
do
so i think that that's is that my
understanding if i'm wrong please
correct me that's that's my concern is
that
we kind of this probably should have
been addressed from the start
but it
whether you support the gun line or not
i think we all should agree that we
shouldn't have that 400 thousand dollars
on positions that don't have a unhappy
task
right i would respect the
authority of the commissioner of safety
to
make appropriate staffing decisions work
with the fiscal committee
if there was adjustments needed to be
made
so my point is i think if you support
the amendment you're not necessarily
supporting getting rid of the
gun lines
and you can understand why because the
bill was filed and
there was no budget when bill was filed
and
we were still i think when the senate
bill went through we were
i mean the house was still working out
above it so we didn't have a finalized
budget
so i can i can understand why this
happened
and why we need to do it it's i think
it's pretty self-explanatory we
just don't want to carry positions and
to tie
up 400 000 of state money
that being said i would agree with you
but we're also in a
higher crunch and i would expect to be
very easily
put these other people into other roles
within the department of safety
rep almost immediately i would expect a
representative to say
that if even if we get rid of these
positions that
they're good employees and they are
going to find a place for them in the
department of safety they're not going
to let them go
worked on the budget we know that the
department safety requested additional
positions from getting them
not
yes
um what we need to do now is to
look at the bill and decide the bill
there's a lot of overlap of what we were
saying at least that was kind of going
on
is there a second second that's been
seconded by representative rory
any further discussion on that
yes those
the motion on the table is to accept the
senate version of
334 yes and then as amended
yes we all in agreement on that
no
we'll be waiting for one and then we
would
just make sure you say this correctly
you will receive to the senate amendment
as amended
i think i repeated myself thank you
that message